SCP-035 Vs SCP-999.
Who would win, this incredibly malicious mask
or the incredibly kind and lovable Tickle
Monster?
Let’s find out.
SCP-035 is an undeniably powerful foe.
From its caustic black liquid, to the incredibly
compelling mental energy that it unleashes
to convince its unwitting victims to put it
on.
But what would this power do against SCP-999?
Being a living blob, it doesn’t have a fixed
face in the traditional sense.
As a result, it may be difficult for 035 to
bond with 999 and thus take it over.
We also believe it’s equally possible that
the powerful good vibes of 999 could counteract
the mental control of SCP-035.
And if it can truly reverse this polarity,
perhaps the nasty mask would chill out for
once.